people are really realizing that
black women don't get the same
recognition as like the normal standard
of beauty
for me it's very important for me to
have like a very diverse cast
and to where everyone sees themselves in
anything that they do
hey guys i'm marseille martin and today
i'm unfiltered
in my home my makeup routine
usually takes me i want to say it gives
me like a good
30 40 minutes just because i'm a
perfectionist and i want everything to
look good
my first makeup step well first i have
this
ponytail holder on because i got long
braids
step one good step what is good
i feel like makeup is also like just a
straight up connection to skin care i'm
gonna use my toner with my uh
chanel pads you see that
chanel yara my
big sister gave it to me for my birthday
so thank you
little spritz
i grew up in little elm texas but i was
born in plano they're like
right by each other but little elm is a
very small town
my first name is kayla so everyone
called me
k bug kayla or
kayla with a c because i had a lot of
kayla's in my class
but yeah i mean it was really cool good
vibes and i feel like i keep that same
energy
here in la because my texas friends were
like
when she moved to l.a she gonna become
something different and then she an
actor too
no she's gonna she gonna become
something different but
no i feel like you know i'm still the
same me and that's what i love about
myself
[Music]
literally i kind of stumbled upon the
entertainment industry like
it was the story is hilarious it was
never like
you know what we're gonna put her into
acting it was it was never like that it
was funny because
um hold on you hear my sister cindy
i'm sorry she playing around it's a
saturday y'all basically how everything
i started was
a photographer i had like my little rock
star outfit i was like
five and long story short
the photographer liked how i took
direction very well
he wanted me to take this acting class
or something
and i literally took like one or two
classes
basically they had this really big thing
where
agents would come and see the kids at
the acting class
and i ended up getting an la agent
so next i wanted to go in with my gel
moisturizer and just put that all around
my grandma told me to always
moisturize up they're calling him
cupcake man
what no going into blackish and
like national commercials and even
pitching little at a young age i was
like
nine or ten and honestly i feel like at
that age i just didn't i didn't care
about
how people would look at me even
pitching little i was like i'm just
talking to my homies at universal the
heads of universal
i really loved how back then
my mind was just carefree fearless
can do whatever without no hesitation
and i feel like that's how
people should be these days like because
i feel like everyone is just
so on the toes of things and don't
really want to use their platform
because
there's cancer culture now or any of
that so i want to do things that make me
happy
and make me feel good and came from my
head space
and yeah i feel like everyone should
think that way
imma just hit two birds with one stone
so basically i go into brows next
and as you see i got some bushy brows
already
i actually use castor oil to
keep making them grow because i mean i
like big brows
i just like to brush it up they're kind
of cool they're kind of fun right now
so now i'm going to go through some of
my meme making
moments that was pretty unexpected at
the time
i don't know why my facial expressions
are the way that they are
you know what i take that back my mom
has the craziest facial expressions like
it's the funniest thing in the world
honestly that's genetic
even at the bet awards
when i won i was shocked and i was just
like
um did i hear my name i did not have my
phone at all
and then when i got home and saw
all the memes that they made already of
me i was just like
my face looks like
it was insane the meme that i got most
surprised by
was probably
on the set of blackish i want to say it
was season one or season two
and i clutched my pearls and i was like
this you look like
like the world's youngest librarian okay
see half the time i make meme i don't
even know i made a me like it's just
that's just my face i thought the uh the
camera was
on to tracy i didn't know it was taking
like the whole the whole thing and i was
just like what
i don't i don't know i don't know all
right so
let's get into the fun stuff now shall
we so i'm gonna go in with
bronzer and all that stuff basically my
eyes
[Music]
being in the public eye is
already insane itself but social media
that's already another thing i feel like
with social media
we were at like one point where it was
like just for fun
for good vibes i'm a savage
classic but now it's like you know what
yeah i'm i'm gonna say it i'ma say it
i feel like social media apps normalize
body shaming and sweat shaming people
have been addressing um my hair or
talking about my hair
it's ridiculous man and i think
that should definitely stop i think
there's there's a lot of influence on
there that i really do
love but what i've noticed is like
the kids make um other kids popular
the people that are still trying to
learn life
and all that so when you see kids
other kids partying during a freaking
pandemic
can't be mad because you are the people
that made him famous
you're the people that made him a
platform so then you're just gonna like
normalize cancel
culture when it's then again just kids
that are still trying to learn there's a
lot of things that are screwed up in
this world
that we really do need to work on
because we are going to be the people
who
build for the next generation
next i feel like i should go in with
eyeliner
y'all we are in quarantine and we got
more things to focus on than just my
hair
just as for brianna taylor i feel like
everything that's been going on right
now
has made people be forced
to actually pay attention to the things
that are going on right now
and now that we are able to
witness and protest and use our
platforms and actually see
the craziness that's been going on for
the past four years
it's it's insane i'm blessed to actually
have the platform that i have
being just a black girl
in like even in like the white male
dominated industry
you have to use your voice um even with
the whole voting situation
like even though i can't vote even
though i got like
two more years i could still use my
platform for the people that can vote
people are really realizing that
black women don't get
like the same recognition as like
the normal standard of beauty you know
[Music]
the normal normal is everyone honestly
for me it's very important for me to
have like a very diverse cast
and to where everyone sees themselves
in anything that they do i feel like for
me it was like the only person that i
saw on screen
that was a black girl at the time
was the sassy black girl that was
uh that was looked at in a certain way
and wasn't smart and was just like
like the bossy girl or even in reality
shows
don't get me wrong i love reality shows
but they always
show the black girl throwing someone's
wig or
like being upset and you know and the
next thing you know they call
us like angry monkeys it's insane
it's really insane i'm grateful that i
got onto blackish and
had like all black hairstylists
and makeup artists and all that and
actually working with people that
really cared about black women i think
oof
would you say i was like i don't know
mom
i'm trying to see how i can say it
when before blackish i was your stylist
i had to always be prepared with my own
tools to do your hair because a lot of
places they didn't have
anybody that and it didn't even matter
they didn't care if they had somebody
that couldn't comb your hair enough
so it was just always an expectation
that i
would bring her already ready for camera
because
they didn't they didn't even care to
have someone who could do anything
to your hair besides turn around and say
oh she looks great you shouldn't you
shouldn't be able
to have to focus on how you look
if you have to like learn your lines and
all of that so i want to make sure that
always i feel my best and i look my best
and i'm just ready to go
it's such a weird feeling sydney
she's skipping around this is how much
foundation i use here watch
i'm joking there's like way more there
you go that's better
kind of give it like an airbrush effect
my mom has influenced me to um
speak up for myself she has
actually built the humor inside of me
like
she has influenced me so much on
just being myself and also being nice to
everyone
i dedicate this award to
all the young girls of color who feel
like
they don't belong or they are just not
seen and
i want you to know that i see you and as
long as i'm pushing the narrative the
world will see you also your first
lackish panel you said you wanted to be
a legend
yes do you feel like you're on your way
i do feel like i'm on my way of being a
legend a legend
means like leaving a mark on the world
and
people not necessarily like knowing your
name
but like your impact
has changed their everyday life
for me back when i was in texas and i
didn't see
young black girls who looked like me i
just thought they weren't
allowed to be on screen and i don't want
anyone
to feel that way and to really
use their talents for the greater good
and not have to worry about
what they look like and um how people
will see them
you know you're not gonna make it far
and that sydney
it's okay bubba she said it's sorry
um but yeah i feel like
just not not to care what people think
do your thing
be who you are and yeah just no worries
about it also i'm going into blush
so i'm just gonna do that i know you
know i know it looks crazy i know that's
crazy you know what i might say
why how'd you do that okay
hold on one one more
i'm doing my makeup so when do you feel
most beautiful
i feel most beautiful when
if i take off my makeup and i'm about to
get into bed
and lay down i really do like my just my
natural
skin i even feel beautiful when i'm with
my friends or family
it makes me feel proud to be who i am
and that's
that's what comes with beauty as well
being proud of who you are and
not not regretting anything and just
really being yourself
oh i can't forget the glasses because i
can't see without them see now i can see
all beautiful faces
[Music]
you